- [Announcer] This program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learned?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
- Welcome to a conversation with history.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Didier Fassin,
who is the James D. Wolfson professor
at the School of Social Science
at the Institute for Advanced Study
in Princeton, New Jersey.
He is the 2016 Tanner
Lecturer at Berkeley.
An anthropologist and a sociologist,
he was trained as a physician
in internal medicine and public health.
His recent books include
The Empire of Trauma,
an Inquiry into the
Condition of Victimhood,
Humanitarian Reason, a Moral
History of the Present,
Enforcing Order, an
Ethnography of Urban Policing,
At the Heart of the State, the
Moral World of Institutions.
His new book, in press, is entitled
Prison Worlds, an Ethnography
of the Carceral World.
Didier, welcome to our program.
- Thank you.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born and raised south of Paris
in the outskirts of the French capital.
I spent my childhood and
adolescence in a housing project.
My parents were, my mother a secretary
and my father, blue collar
worker in a car factory.
- And looking back, how did your parents
shape your thinking about the world?
- I think my father in particular
had a sense of duty, of righteousness.
And he was absolutely not an intellectual,
neither my mother was.
But they both had this principle
that you find in working class families,
where you have to work on
meritocracy principles.
- And when you say a housing project,
was it one where there were
minorities and immigrants?
- Absolutely.
But the difference with
the housing projects
as they are now is, at that
time, they were more mixed.
So they were all working
class people, low income,
but you would find French
as well as immigrants.
And this is the surroundings
and the friends I had when I was a kid.
- And what imbued you with the ethos
of education and training?
- Well, I would say
that there was not much
in this working class
housing project environment
and school was a way to escape that
through the studies, but also through
the possibilities of, perhaps,
doing something different.
And I remember that, for my parents,
and probably they told me
that when I was a child,
or maybe a little later,
that for them, having a child,
a son who would be a physician,
was something that was
simply impossible to imagine,
because it seems such
a distant social world.
So yes, I think the school was this place
where you could move from
one world to another.
- And your first career, shall
we say, was as a physician.
So you went to medical school.
- I went to medical school.
And I had decided to study medicine
at the time of the
liberation war of Bangladesh.
That's one of the first moments
when we had, in 1971, 1972,
on television, you
would see the situations
of the Bangladeshi, and the
intervention of the Indian Army.
So this is when I decided
to study medicine,
with the idea that I would
perhaps, at some point,
go abroad and do some
work in other countries.
- Is this common in France,
or was this unique to your career,
the notion that you
would apply these skills
in worldwide humanitarian work?
- Well, at the time, it was,
it was certainly not common,
but there was a minority that
came out almost in that same period,
that's the famous Doctors Without Borders.
So my case was certainly not unique,
but in my class at the faculty of medicine
at the University of Paris,
I didn't know any other friend or student
who had this view for his future.
- So, in your career in medicine,
you essentially became a doctor
with a constituency that was worldwide.
So first you went to Bangladesh.
- So when I became a physician,
I did what my colleagues
at the time were doing,
except that I had taken a test
to remain in public hospitals.
So I worked in public hospitals in France.
I became a specialist in internal medicine
and infectious diseases.
And at some point, I had the opportunity,
before doing my civil service,
which, for physicians, can replace,
could, at the time,
replace military service,
so my civil service I did in Tunisia,
but before that, I went to Calcutta,
where I worked as the physician
in charge of the Home
for Dying Destitutes.
So I started in a very banal way,
being in a public hospital,
being an intern and then resident.
And at some point there
was this bifurcation
that was opened to me, of
doing what I had wanted
to do when I started medicine.
So part of my work as a physician,
a good part of it, has been working
in France in public hospitals,
and at some point doing
some international work,
mostly in these two
countries, India and Tunisia.
- And later, really, all over the world,
on different continents.
- So, later, after I
became an anthropologist,
and a social scientist,
I returned to medicine
in two different ways.
First, I created and
became the coordinator
for several years of a socio-medical unit
in a public hospital near Paris,
in an area where there
were a lot of immigrants,
some of them being undocumented,
and so having no medical insurance.
And so I opened this unit
to take care of their
medical, social, and even legal problems.
And so that's one thing.
And the other one is
that I became involved,
I had been, for a long time,
with different
non-governmental organizations,
including Doctors of the World,
which was a dissident branch
of Doctors Without Borders,
but at some point I was asked to join
the administration board and later become
vice president of Doctors Without Borders.
But at that time, I was a
professor at the university,
so I was not going in the field
as much as I had done before.
So I was more contributing to the politics
and the reflection around the politics
of the humanitarian organization.
- Now from medicine, I surmise that,
and this is a guess, so correct me,
that you honed your skills in
terms of listening to people,
to their case studies, and I guess
you became aware, I suspect,
of the relationship of their story,
their biography, what you
were learning in the consult,
and the relationship to the body, really,
a sense of the body as separate from that.
- Yeah.
I have really enjoyed the time
when I was involved in clinical medicine.
I like the relationship
you had with people,
especially toward the
end of my medical career.
Because I was working with
these undocumented immigrants.
And we had more time to spend with them,
to understand their problems.
But more generally, I think
that, most of the time,
we don't get very deep
in the personal histories
and the social context of the patient
that we have in clinical medicine.
In fact, I did a study of 100
cases in the emergency room,
and there was not one case in which
the social context of
the person had been asked
in the public hospital
where I did this study.
And I think that's very revealing of
an interaction which is very much
concentrated on the body, as you said,
examining it, finding the symptoms
and signs that will lead you
to a diagnosis and perhaps treatment.
So this personal, deeper interaction
is something that I didn't
really find with medicine.
I found it, but at a
very superficial level.
- And at some point, do you then decide
that you need to do more in your education
in terms of theoretical, and in terms
of anthropology and ethnography?
- Well I think that it came
with my experience of going to
India and then Tunisia,
but India in particular.
And this encounter with a different world,
which I had no experience of before,
was marked by, I think
retrospectively, by two elements.
One is the extreme inequality that
you find in a city like Calcutta.
And it is very puzzling to see the gap
between the wealthy and
very very poor people.
And the other one was this vibrant culture
that was so different
from Western culture.
So I think this combination
of inequality and culture
brought me to a form
of, well, a questioning,
which I realized afterwards,
I didn't even know the word anthropology,
which I realized could find some answers
by studying the social science.
And in France, we have an intellectual
tradition in social
science in which we don't
separate sociology and
anthropology very much.
So I was, in fact, a
professor of sociology,
and I was a director of
studies in anthropology.
And so, that helped to
make this combination
between what I found interesting
in different cultures,
and what I found so important
to understand about inequality.
- You are an ethnographer on the one hand,
but you also seem to be a theorist.
And I like to ask my guests
the skills and temperament that they think
are involved in the work they do.
What are really important
skills for the ethnographer.
For the ethnographer,
I think what is needed
is, first of all,
obviously, a deep interest
in the worlds that you study
and the people who inhabit these worlds.
That's, I think, both the motivation and,
I don't know if it's a skill,
but at least a competence
that you should have.
Then what is extremely
important is the humility.
When you do an ethnography, you come into
the lives of people who have never asked
to have someone getting
in their existence.
So you have to be very available for them,
and sometimes, that happened to me
in my work in Ecuador for
example, or South Africa,
people would let you wait for half a day
before spending some time with you.
And this experience of understanding that
you have to be open to the moments
when people want to give
you some of their time,
so I think these are two qualities
or elements that are needed.
Patience is also something
that is important,
because ethnography is really based
on duration, on spending time.
It's completely different from
doing interviews, for example.
- [Harry] Or journalism.
- Or journalism, of course.
I've been working on the police,
and I spent 16 months studying
police units in a specific area.
I didn't do a study of the whole country.
Whereas journalists working, some of them
working on the same topic,
would spend one night with the police
and then do an article.
So they're different jobs,
different practice and
different ethos, I think.
- There also seems to be an element
of sympathy here, and a respect
for the integrity of the culture
that you're immersing yourself in.
Is that fair?
- Yeah, absolutely.
You have to be curious about,
genuinely curious, so
you don't come with your
opinions that you would impose.
So even if you disagree with what people
say or think, or the way they act,
this is not something that
you have to put forward.
You have to try to understand, really.
And you have to respect,
individually also,
to respect the persons they are.
And of course, it is
often relatively easy,
because, especially if you
do, like I've been doing,
work with people who are
in difficult situations,
because they are asylum seekers,
because they are undocumented immigrants,
because they are AIDS
patients or AIDS orphans.
But it becomes a little more difficult
when you deal with people who are,
for example, police officers.
And still, you need to have this sympathy,
which does not mean that you
will approve of what they do.
But still, you have to have to try to have
this understanding and this neutrality
at the same time, with what you see.
- And you're listening,
you're questioning, you're being present.
And when I say questioning,
you're not being adversarial,
you're really trying to figure
out, it's like a puzzle.
You're trying to figure
out what's going on here,
what motivates this cop on, you know,
this part of this crime squad.
- Yeah.
Yeah, as you say, puzzled in a metaphor
that I use, taking it from Georges Perec,
his book, Life A User's Manual.
And yes, the work with the police
is consisted, as
ethnography more generally,
really, first of all, in a presence.
And trying to be as discrete as possible,
not to interfere with their
interactions with the public,
not to comment on what
would have happened,
or to comment, at least,
in a questioning way,
asking why did things happen this way,
rather than appearing to be judgemental,
because then, people close themselves.
So yeah, it is this puzzle
that you try to reconstitute
through this long time when,
in the work with the
police, my main experience,
which I realized, after a long time,
that was a shared experience
with the police, was boredom.
Nothing happened most of the time.
And so, what does it
mean for police officers
who are supposed to be
in action all the time,
arresting thugs, as they say, and thieves,
to be in the car or to
be walking in the street
and having nothing to do
except trying to look around?
So this, ethnography for
me is, of course, a method,
where you spend this long
period of time with people.
But it's also an experience
that you share with the people,
and this experience is extremely important
for the last dimension of ethnography,
which, etymologically, is writing.
So ethnography is about writing also.
And the writing moment is, I think,
as important as the work
you've been doing in the field.
- And I'm curious about that, and that is,
you go out with the police, you come home,
and then you do your notes?
Or are you taking notes as you're
going around with the police?
- No, I could not record.
That was, I would have liked
to, but that was impossible.
- By record, you mean a tape recorder?
- With a tape recorder.
So I was not allowed to have one,
and I didn't cheat on that.
And I could not, or I would not,
take notes while being in the car,
because that would have put me
in a different position with the police.
If people are speaking
and you're taking notes,
it puts them on the defensive, in a way.
And I prefer to try to let them be like,
as much as possible, as
if I were not present.
Of course, I know that I was,
I know that some things, for example,
physical violence, would not happen
because I was present most of the time.
But at least I tried to avoid this
too obvious presence of the researcher
who is writing while people,
so I had this conversation with them,
and when I was back home,
I would immediately start to write.
That's what I did with my
work on the prison also.
I would rarely take notes.
I did sometimes, in the prison,
because the spaces were different,
but in the car with the
police I didn't do that.
- We'll go back to writing in a minute,
but I did wanna pick up one other element.
In your new book, you talk about
the multidimensional
perspective of your work.
Talk to us about that, 'cause that means
you're not just following
the officer on the beat
or the officer in the squad car.
You're talking to their superiors,
you're talking to their
administrators, and so on.
- Yeah, so I think ethnography gives us
a very unique approach
of certain social worlds,
like the one of the police,
the one of the prison,
or the one of disaster victims,
as I have done in the past.
But it is never sufficient,
or it should not.
I'm not, although I've been
influenced by interactionism,
but I'm not an interactionist in the sense
that I don't think that, although they
would not say it exactly in this way,
but everything is played in
the moment of the interaction.
I like to, first of all, to
multiply the perspectives,
the perspectives from other people
in their immediate environment,
like their superiors, but also
inhabitants of the neighborhoods
where the police intervene.
And then I try to inscribe or interpret
these local scenes and these,
the life of these institutions,
in a broader framework or background,
which is both historical and political.
And I try to, for example, to understand
the evolution of the
police or the prison system
in France over the years.
I try to understand the composition,
the socio-demographic composition of,
who are the police officers?
Who are the correctional officers?
Because this is very indicative and very
essential to the understanding of
why they act the way they act.
- So this is the other hat that you wear,
and I'll call it a theorist, basically,
'cause what you're bringing is history,
sociology, anthropology, to step back.
And you write somewhere
that you see yourself
operating at the frontier
between inside and outside.
So wearing this new hat, it is incumbent
upon you to be detached, in a way,
and to become the scholar of how we
got to a particular
place, with the police,
with humanitarianism, with the prisons,
in order to give a fuller
picture of what this means.
Because you're coming to an understanding
that the people who are the actors
in the situation, the police, the prisons,
they may not understand.
- Absolutely.
So the idea of the threshold of the cave,
which is, of course, Plato's Cave,
Michael Walzer, in his book
The Company of Critics,
who is, Michael Walzer,
who is my colleague
at the Institute for Advanced Study,
uses this metaphor to
oppose the intellectuals
or thinkers or theorists who are
outside the cave, and look at the world,
at the illusions that
people have within the cave,
whereas others, and he counts
himself as one of them,
try to be close to the people
and try to understand them
and their contradictions,
and their dilemmas, et cetera.
And what I've proposed to
do and what I've tried to do
is, and that had been a very intense
debate in France, between Pierre Bordieu,
who was on the outside of the cave,
to use this allegory, and Luc Boltanski,
a student who was rather inside,
and I thought that being on the threshold
was not only a way to avoid this debate,
but precisely to show
that, as an ethnographer,
you have to be with the people,
you have to try to understand them,
and you have to be honest about
how much you owe them in your
comprehension of the world,
and how much you must recognize
their intelligence of the world,
how they understand the
world in which they are,
and help you understand.
But this is not sufficient,
because people are
blind on certain things,
they may want to avoid
seeing certain things
or understanding certain logics of their,
of what they do and why they do it.
And moving outside the cave is a way
to bring a critical, broader perspective
on things that escape them,
as they would escape any of
us when we are in our world.
So it's this combination of
moving inside and outside
that I try to do, and theory,
in particular critical theory
is, I think, a way to do it,
and also to, for me, critical theory
is also a way to find larger issues
in the transformation of
contemporary societies.
- And in all of these areas that you work,
what you find by putting this together,
the ethnography on the one hand,
the theory and history and
sociology on the other,
is that what people think is going on
isn't actually going on,
or if they set a set of moral standards
for what they're doing,
this mix of ethnography and theory
leads you often to a conclusion
that something else is going on.
And often what is at work here
is a hidden inequality, shall we say.
- Absolutely.
I think one of the ways I use theory,
and, in a sense, anthropology as such,
is the capacity to be surprised,
to be astonished by what we
usually take for granted.
What we take for granted,
in particular, in moral dimensions,
or what we think is good,
what we think is bad.
And so it's not a relativist perspective.
It's not to say
what you think is good, in fact, is bad,
or all values are possible.
It is a way to step aside
and try to do what Michel
Foucault was writing about
for the bicentenary of
What Is Enlightenment,
the text by Kant, and saying that
critique is really in that capacity
to question what we take for granted,
what we think as self-evident.
So this is one aspect
in which I think that
our work as social scientists
can bring something.
For example, since I'm
now working on punishment,
the fact that, in other societies
or in other times in our own society,
the treatment by society
of violations of the law
were not in terms of punishing
or inflicting suffering,
but were very much involved
in an economy of exchange,
of repaying a debt.
Which you find some elements
still in our law today,
and even more in Islamic law.
So this is the kind of questioning
that I think anthropology allows us.
It allows us by the fact that
we work in different societies
and we understand that
the world as we know it,
especially the world that is close to us,
is only one of the possibilities,
and probably not the ultimate possibility.
And so, this is interesting both
from an intellectual perspective,
and I would say also from
a political or citizen perspective.
The world is what it is,
but it could have been different,
and it can still be different,
depending on the actions of men and women.
So it gives a connection between
intellectual activity and
possible political activity.
- Let's take some examples.
So in the study of humanitarianism,
what you, the good appears to be
people doing worthwhile things for people
who are suffering because of illness,
of war, of natural disaster, and so on.
But as you probe this, what you discover
is that there is an inequality
and there is an emphasis on the suffering,
which obscures the biographies
and the stories that
the people have to tell.
And so what makes us feel
very good, say, in the West,
about what we're doing,
raises all sorts of questions,
because in the end,
this charity, in quotes,
is displacing an understanding
of the political issues
that are at stake both
locally and internationally.
- So I think that's a very good example
of how critical thinking can help us
address an issue such as humanitarianism.
Of course, there's a general sense
that humanitarianism is good,
assisting people or aiding individuals
who are in dire situations,
conflict and disasters,
in famine, in poverty.
And I'm not questioning that,
whether it's good or bad.
What I'm trying to,
first of all, understand
is why is it that, in
the late 20th Century,
humanitarianism has
become such an important
part of the way we govern populations?
And from international relations
to local worlds of neighborhoods.
- Charitable contributions, philanthropy.
- Exactly.
So this has not been forever.
So first of all, to try to identify that,
that it's a new phenomenon.
And it's a new phenomenon that is deeply
with a contradiction that
is, I think, impassable.
And that's what we can call an aporia.
Which is, on the one
hand, it is a solidarity.
So you want to help people.
But on the other hand,
there's a structural
inequality that is at stake.
So the one who is helping is asymmetrical
from the one who is being helped.
And when I say that, it's not that I want
to criticize one aspect or the other.
It's that it will help us understand,
first of all, the resentment
that people who are
helped sometimes express
against or toward the
person who helps them,
but also, on the side of the helper,
the kind of compassion fatigue
that they very often express.
So that's a very general element
about the deep contradiction
in humanitarianism.
And when I say it's impassable,
it's because it is the
core of humanitarianism.
It's not because you will be
a better humanitarian worker,
and of course you can, but
that you will change that.
That's a very deep element.
But then, as you said, you have a series
of consequences that you see on the ground
in the field of this
humanitarian intervention.
One is that you, because you want to
speak for the victims of these situations
where you intervene, you are inclined
to speak in their stead, and to
make their voice much less heard.
Sometimes these voices are too
difficult to be heard anyway.
But for example, you have people,
young people in Palestine
who see themselves
as struggling for their country,
and you transform them into
victims of trauma, for example.
And they are, of course.
But then you obliterate the other aspect.
- It's a political problem.
- Exactly, so you transform
a political message
that they have into a moral
or sometimes even medical
or psychological issue.
But there's also, at the marginal level,
and we see that toward the
end of the 20th Century
and beginning of the new one,
the language of humanitarianism
has tended to replace
and make less hearable
the language of social justice.
And it's not because
the humanitarian workers
are against social justice.
It's just that it occupies a space
that was previously more legitimately
occupied by social justice.
For example, to continue on Palestine,
because I've been doing some work
on the humanitarian actions in Palestine,
you see that when you transform
resistance into resilience,
violence into trauma,
you're changing the perception
that we have of these,
this political context.
So this is the kind of thing that
I try to do on humanitarianism.
It's not a frontal critique,
and myself, I have been involved in that,
and I have no regrets in having been so,
but it's really trying to precisely,
as an insider but also now an outsider,
try to understand, what are the stakes
and what are the consequences of this
humanitarian government, as we have it.
- One of the important
points that need to be made
is that, although you
take a particular case
and immerse yourself in
that particular case,
that the end result of this is kind of
a general statement
analysis, a critical theory
rendering understanding
that applies elsewhere.
And so, I was struck in reading your book
on the police in this French suburb
filled with immigrants and refugees,
that it was very applicable
for understanding
what has been going on
in the United States
and led to the Black Lives
Matter movement here,
where police, and you use the term,
quoting Benjamin, "rule
by exception" basically.
And so, it really helps an American
understand what's going
on in our own ghettos,
even though that was not
the focus of your work.
- I think what you're
saying is very important.
Ethnography, because of the very deep
involvement in time and
energy that it requires,
cannot be multiplied in
different sites, countries.
It can be, under a certain limit,
for example, when you work with a team,
which is what I've been
doing a few years ago.
We were 10 researchers and were exploring,
by ethnography, the state,
as we said, the French state.
So some were working
in the justice system,
other in prison, other with the police,
other with the social workers, et cetera.
But, as an individual, you spend,
in the case of the prison,
four years in the same facility,
in the same short stay prison.
And of course, an answer that you can,
or a reaction that you can get is,
what you described here
is valid for this place,
but of course, is not
valid for everywhere.
And of course, that is true.
I could not assert that
what I've described
with the police in one place
or the prison in another place
would be generalizable to all
prisons and all the police.
But I think the question of generalization
has to be thought in two different ways,
which can be represented in the following.
So, you have a horizontal generalization,
meaning that, for example, those who do
epidemiological studies
or statistical studies,
they take a sample and,
because this sample is randomly chosen,
they can generalize to
the whole population.
That's how the polls are working
for political opinions, for example.
So this is a horizontal generalization.
What you've seen in different places,
you can say that's true
for the whole group.
There's a different type of generalization
that ethnography, and
other methods, can allow,
what I would call vertical generalization,
meaning that you can
identify a process, a logic.
Why, for example, the police
react in a certain way
to a certain type of situation.
And this can be generalized,
not in the sense that you could say
all the police anywhere in the world
can act in the same way,
but these ways of acting,
you will find everywhere.
And of course, it's not even generalizable
to the place where you've been working,
but the processes, the
logic, the mechanisms
are to be found everywhere.
And I think that's a very
powerful argument for ethnography,
and this has also political implications,
because when you do a work
on the police in France
and your colleagues tell you,
well it's valid in this place
but it has no validity elsewhere,
it means that you cannot
take any general conclusions.
But when you go to Brazil
or to the United States
or to South Africa,
and you meet colleagues
who are criminologists
and who've read your work
and say, this is exactly what we see,
they don't mean that the police
in South Africa, Brazil,
or the United States
are the same as the police in France,
but the mechanism, the processes,
they find, are the same.
- So that in a way, I mean
when I read your book,
and I thought about the American ghettos,
what you see is a similarity in the fact
that these are underprivileged,
poverty-ridden communities,
and I see an emphasis on law and order
that's coming from the top, and that,
in the case of Europe, is mingled with
concerns about terrorism, creating quotas
to arrest and harass
people in these areas,
whether it's through checking
their pockets for marijuana
or enforcing traffic tickets,
that then create a loop
in which these people,
something else is going
on besides law enforcement
in the case of the police.
There's a bigger picture here
that is rooted in inequality,
and actually, politics actually,
because the people over
the police, for example,
are creating quotas to measure,
and the politicians wanna
respond to the fear of people.
- Yeah.
It's very important to link what you see
on the ground, the way
the police are acting,
with the institution that they belong to,
the profession in which they participate,
and the general policies.
And when you have law and order policies,
from the police academy to
the supervision of the work,
when you have the idea
that certain neighborhoods
are to be police property, in a sense,
where the welfare state
is not very consistent,
and you turn to the repressive side,
so this is something that has to be
taken into account, to
understand that, in the end,
and that's what I try to
show in Enforcing Order,
is that, instead of
enforcing a public order,
what happens is that the police
are enforcing social order.
So they remind the people of
low income minority background,
and living in housing
projects in particular,
they remind them their place in society.
So it's not that they
would arrest criminals,
or that they would stop drug dealers.
They harass young men,
or sometimes immigrants,
but most of the time young
men of immigrant background,
and they know them, and they
pass them their documents
and then they search them,
and they do that everyday.
So you cannot think of this as
public security or public order.
And in fact, their superiors
know that very well.
They've told me that these units
were often creating more
problems than they were solving.
But then you have to ask yourself,
so why are they working
these neighborhoods
if it's not, mainly, I'm
not saying that they're not
arresting criminals in
some cases, of course,
but their main role is to maintain,
not a public order, but a social order.
And that's what you find, obviously,
in the kind of relationship that you see
in the American inner cities, for example.
- In your new book, which is in press,
I saw this line in reading
the parts that I've read.
"Ethnography derives from a project
"whereby the anthropologist
strives both to understand,"
and we've talked a lot about
how you come to understand,
"and to lead others to understand."
So I guess I wanna ask
about the second part.
That is, how do these
insights have an impact,
how do you think they have an impact?
And how do you hope they will
impact society in actual policy?
- In recent years, I've tried to reflect
more than I used to and more than we do,
in anthropology and sociology,
on what I've called the public
afterlife of ethnography,
or the public afterlife of
our work more generally.
So we as social scientists
usually think that
there's an empirical and
theoretical moment in our work,
and then we translate this ethnography
or statistics and theorization
of it into articles, books,
and then we move on to the next project.
And I think we can, first of all,
be more attentive to the
kinds of interactions
we have with our public,
and also try to extend
the publics that we have.
So we know that, for
example, the economists,
at least some of them, publish
their very specific articles
in the best journals of their discipline,
but they can also write books
that have a more general audience.
And we, even the
anthropologists have done that.
You have Claude Lvi-Strauss
writing structural anthropology,
or before that, writing on kinship,
but at the same time,
writing Tristes Tropiques.
So the question is, how can you reach
a public that is not just your colleagues,
but a broader audience,
if the topics on which you work
are of general interest?
And this goes somewhat against
some of the academic rules.
Or at least academic habits.
But I think it's important
for the social sciences,
and perhaps anthropology in particular,
to reach out for broader audiences,
to have a place in the public sphere,
because we produce empirical
and theoretical elements
that can be appropriated
either by the policy makers
or by the activists or by
the population themselves.
So this public afterlife, I think,
should be taken into account
much more than it is the case.
- I regret to say our time is up,
but I wanna thank for very much
for these powerful insights into the work
of ethnography and critical theory.
And I do wanna propose to our audience
that they take a look at some
of the books we've discussed.
Humanitarian Reason, Enforcing Order,
an Ethnography of Urban Policing,
At the Heart of the State, the
Moral World of Institutions,
and finally, your new book,
in press, Prison Worlds.
So thank you very much,
Didier, for being with us.
- Thank you Harry.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this conversation with history.